(upbeat music)
(rewind sound)
(wind chimes)
(man throws up)
- (Screams) aah!
- God, are you kidding me?
- Ew!
- You know, we love the
movie Sliding Doors.
I mean, that's a
90s movie, right?
Like the wind chimes,
it's just so cheesy.
- Cheesy as hell, dog.
So cheesy.
- But it's such an
interesting thing,
it's about the idea of
what if a little teeny
thing happened in your life
that could completely change
the course of your life.
- I'm Abbi.
- I'm Ilana.
- We originally wrote a
version of this episode
in season one.
- Because we didn't know
that we were definitely
gonna get a second
season, no less four,
and so we were like,
we wanna make it
feel like a series finale.
- Amy Poehler, who
is an EP on the show,
felt very strongly that
it was too soon. (laughs)
- We were pissed!
- 'Cause when you watch a
show, you have to be invested
in the characters to
care about how they met.
And it would've been so--
- But she was right,
it was really really
good to push it.
- It was too soon.
(scissors snipping noise)
- Ha ha!
- What, no!
Oh my God.
- What happened?
- He took my pony!
- That wig is unbelievable.
It felt like a wig to me.
But people didn't--
- But it looked like her hair.
- I had to walk around all day
in that wig on lunch--
- Everybody was Instagramming
you being like, you
got bangs again?
- I know.
- New bangs!
- The clothes were disgusting.
- We wanted to capture like
how you don't know how to
dress your body in your
early twenties or whatever.
- I was always like
belting stuff like that.
- Belting, and your
flats were horrible.
- It's just exactly how
I dressed at that time.
- What was my shoes?
Oh my God, my shoes.
- Yours was disgusting,
even though I had them.
- Huaraches?
Me too! I had them too.
- I think they had
them like last year,
still I wasn't
really wearing them
they were just in my closet.
- Go go go go!
(glass breaks)
(siren wailing)
- Oh my God!
- Go, go go!
The pizza!
- Leave it!
(siren wailing)
(horn honking)
(crash sound)
- At one point when
we were rewriting it,
we were like, what
are we even saying?
You know, in Sliding
Doors it's like,
if you see the truth
it's better, but you die?
- What are we even saying?
- I forget how the movie ends.
- I love that though.
- But we were like,
we're friends either way.
- A new friend.
- The version where we're
apart, it is an upsetting day,
for both of us, it's like
what are their lives like
without each other?
- Yeah, their lives would
suck without each other.
- We added some stuff.
- Yeah.
- Hey.
- What we were trying to
say is that inevitably
these two would've found each
other and become friends.
- Some people you're
just destined to meet
and fall in love with.
(both laughing)
(upbeat music)